Bonjour je me présente Paton Olivier
j'habite à saint-andré donc ça fait UN
an et UN mois Que j'ai créé Mon
entreprise c'est service à la personne
donc ménage et repassage à domicile donc
le ménage c'est beaucoup à la vapeur et
les huiles essentielles et du vinaigre
Blanc donc c'est UN ménage écologie je
ramène tout Mon matériel chez la
personne donc Que soit Ma machine Pour
aspirer et Qui nettoie en même temps à
La vapeur Qui nettoie aussi les B vitrés
les sanitaires les canapés et les lits
dans Va Dire ça fait 10 ANS je suis dans
la restauration en métropole je suis
arrivé Ici j'ai sur Va Dire pendant les
10 ANS la restauration je faisais Le
repassage Pour Mes clients sur Va Dire
Des clients asseés sur Va Dire Des Stars
américains donc je faisais leur repage
et aussi UN peu Le Nettoyage De leur
chambres donc même si j'étais sur Va Dire
mre d'hôtel on faisait UN peu tout dans
l'hôtel donc voilà c'est c'est Une
passion Le ménage cuisine et Le
repassage c'est Une passion Que voilà
Que j'ai depuis longtemps et j'ai dit
pourquoi pas pourquoi les autres ils
réussissent pourquoi pas Moi donc je me
suis lancé et Pour l'instant ça Marche
on est là Pour voilà Dire faire UN petit
peu De pub sur Va Dire c'est UN petit
plus c'est c'est UN Trin passe et on
c'est UN gra à vous si on peut avir Des
clients crer Des emplo Sur la crise en
Ce moment c'est possible CR Des emplois
et Grand la
société